resident evil is returning to the big
screen with a new live-action movie
resident evil welcome to raccoon city
set for release on november 24th 2021.
sony released the trailer for the movie
on october 7th surprising gamers with a
little midweek zombie mayhem the trailer
also featured more than a few details
that only true fans would notice
blank during the trailer and you might
miss a reference to the iconic opening
scene from resident evil 2 and its
remake almost seamlessly recreated for
welcome to raccoon city things start
innocently enough with the truck driver
calmly driving down the highway
listening to a radio program then after
hearing an ominous comment about
monsters on the radio the driver
encounters a zombie in the middle of the
road things don't go so well for the
driver when he gets out to investigate
as the body begins to rise behind him
presumably to attack later the driver
returns fully overtaken by whatever
affliction is affecting the city driving
his semi straight toward leon and claire
the original resident evil 2 featured a
similar scene so it only makes sense
that they would recreate the sequence
for a resident evil movie the trailer
for welcome to raccoon city shows the
driver that looks extremely similar to
the one in the games sporting the same
well-groomed beard and hat in the
trailer the driver's eyes are completely
black with dark veins creeping along the
edges of his face while the short
sequence doesn't show him chasing claire
or leon viewers do get to see his semi
overturn crashing right in front of the
raccoon city police department
every story has a beginning
fans who have played the original
resident evil or its remake will no
doubt remember the bone chilling
experience of stumbling across the
game's very first zombie well resident
evil welcome to raccoon city wants you
to feel that same sense of terror when
you watch it on the big screen the movie
trailer shows a scene with a zombie in a
lab coat that's in the exact same
position as the first zombie you meet in
the original resident evil it certainly
looks more faithful to the games than
those mila jovovich movies
people are getting sick one reference in
the trailer is just two words itchy and
tasty this is a reference to an infamous
journal that players discovered back in
the original resident evil game the
harrowing diary told the tale of
someone's descent into becoming a zombie
with the last haunting entry simply
reading itchy tasty the two words became
iconic for the series to the point where
the official resident evil twitter
account actually tweeted the words in
august 2021 to get fans hyped for the
upcoming movie it worked out as the
simple phrase earned over 20 000 likes
we need to expose umbrella the trailer
for resident evil welcome to raccoon
city uses iconic locations like the
spencer mansion and police station to
demonstrate that the film will pull
elements from both resident evil and
resident evil 2 to tell its story that
includes some of the series most
infamous characters at one point a
dossier appears on screen and fans who
look closely will notice two critical
names printed at the top of the file is
lisa trevor whose story was featured
heavily in the remake of the first
resident evil game a tragic figure who
was experimented on and used to create
the g-virus she's easily one of the
scariest resident evil villains it's
also worth noting that a clue at the
bottom of the dossier may reveal that
her movie origin story will match that
of the games the signature on the file
reads w birkin which resident evil fans
know can stand for only one man dr
william birkin according to deadline
birkin will be played by neil mcdonough
and if fans back up the trailer a couple
of frames they will see him as the evil
virologist who not only experimented on
lisa but also kicked off the horrific
events of resident evil 2.
good god william
what have you done
on top of the dossier is what looks like
a film canister with the label ashford
twins tying the movie into the events of
resident evil code veronica
you don't fool me
i am alfred ashford
the opening moments of the resident evil
welcome to raccoon city trailer waste no
time in letting fans know that things
are not going well under the umbrella
corporation's watch an early moment in
the trailer highlights members of the
umbrella security service or uss
patrolling a locked down raccoon city
one shot stands out amongst the rest
while it can be tough to be sure without
more context a soldier wearing a gas
mask has a definite resemblance to hunk
hunk is the code name of an umbrella
operative also known as mr death due to
his seeming ability to survive every
major umbrella related disaster his
exploits may not always be canonical to
the games but he's a popular character
among fans and quite a deep cut
reference for this movie again it's hard
to confirm that the gas masked
individual is actually the legendary uss
operative but it could provide a
possible setup for future films hunk was
after all the character who extracted
samples of the g-virus and the t-virus
after an encounter with dr birkin so
it's not out of the question that he's
in the movie too check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite movies
and tv shows are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you